how's it going everyone name's Pierre ba
and we're actually not gonna play video
games today we're gonna read someone
recommended this I really don't know
what I expect
but it's this warning this web tour this
special our episode for this summer
season says it contains shocking scenes
reader discretion is advised for
pregnant women really huh do dirty and
those suffering from serious medical
conditions wow this is that warning mmm
that can change what I'm about to expect
what am I about to expect what about his
experience bong Chun Doong ghost this
story is based on true I witness account
[ __ ] go down Jesus penis it was
around the 11:20 that night I was
dragging myself home exhausted oh wait
she's a girl I was dragging that was
dragging myself home exhausted after a
tiring night study sessions at school
but there was no one on the streets
which I thought was changed I sure
didn't see a lot of people even at night
since my apartment complex is pretty big
anyways I feeling scared I kept the get
down on the ground while walking home
suddenly a shadow stretching towards me
me caught my eyes although there wasn't
anyone around me I looked up to see who
there was I saw a woman walking in front
of me but she looked a little strange
yeah she's facial right
he's breakdancing no that's what she's
doing like I could say that Sheila
crippled she was lamenting and
struggling to walk in front of me since
she was walking very slow as soon cut
off with her of clothes I was able to
see her even better she was wearing a
dirty pink pajamas and looked as if her
joints in her body had been twisted
worse her hair was a mess is sticking
out too everywhere yeah that's the worst
part her hair it seems so weird that I
stopped walking I felt like I shouldn't
get any closer to her nor did I have the
guts to pass her behind my [ __ ] legs
ah you like that ah
okay I get the warning now I get the
[ __ ] warning I get the Wow I need a
pillow or something bong Chun
[ __ ] oh oh oh man oh man you
[ __ ] Japanese [ __ ] Asians I don't
oh my god you know people say that if
you are really surprised
you can't even scream that was right I
froze they're not being able to move at
all where is my baby
my thought my thoughts were racing to
her question oh my god I don't even know
what I was thinking
when I did that it gives me the chills
thinking that moment gulp
answered pointing as far as I could Oh
over there I just wanted her to get away
from me
then she limped towards where I was
pointing to and I couldn't see her
anymore futuring fearing that I might
run into her again
I tried to turn around and leave the
apartment complex I could not think of
anything but to get out of the place
where they would be people around at
that moment she's not I'm glad I have oh
my god
okay keep reading I guess yeah I don't
remember anything from then on I heard
that my neighbor found me passed out on
the ground and take me home in 2007 at
an apartment complex
Oh in 2007 at an apartment complex in
bong Chun Doong bana boo
Thao 30 year old woman jumped off the
part in a dead spot known as surnamed
Cho a divorce due to her extra at
marshal affair she had lost her custody
of a two year old daughter and I decided
to make a suicide after that incident
she was seen walking around apartment
complex several times that angel was
seeing why does it say twice holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was the worst thing
I've ever read in my entire life I don't
know what to say about that oh my god oh
my [ __ ] god
yeah thanks forever suggested that I
need to go and change my pants
but yeah thumbs up the video